you think playing like a girl is easy
let me show you what it takes
playing like a girl is a hustle don't
expect to be paid like Messi or Ronaldo
there's money in the woman's game but
not much be ready to get an extra job or
two playing like a girl means you have
to do your biggest fan because the
cameras won't always be focused on you
and if you want to catch their eye or
even get a sponsor people will tell you
to use your look
they may even tell you to listen to Sepp
Blatter
and wear tighter shorts to get a bigger
audience
playing like a girl means that when you
get to the World Cup you're armed to the
teeth with nothing but resilience you're
not competing on an equal playing field
because your field will make you bleed
burn and bruise even more and you take
it like a girl playing like a girl means
having thick skin you'll be told that
your game is boring but you're not as
skilled as the guys and what you achieve
won't be cause for celebration
but you have the satisfaction of knowing
that a woman has outscored the likes of
Neymar Benzema Suarez and Ronaldinho and
when you play like a girl you never let
your guard down you keep your eyes on
the ball because though uncertainty
rules your world it doesn't rule you
yeah the odds are great but since when
do you back down from a challenge
you are fierce and prepared you are
ready to outrun the naysayers the haters
and anyone who told you you're weak
because you've got what it takes
you